bom eu sou rayan ea provável que você
não lembre meu nome no fim do dia
mas vou te garante uma coisa você vai
lembrar de uma palavra camaleão
esse é o tdf barra da tijuca e eu pude
visitei 77 países na minha vida e esse
teste importante para mim porque minha
formação aconteceu alguns passos de
distância desse teatro no colégio santo
agostinho um colégio tradicional colégio
playboy está ligado
só que a minha formação eu cresci entre
os bairros de vila da penha e complexo
do alemão
então eu cresci com uma crise de
identidade enorme porque eu era muito
playboy para o pessoal do subúrbio e
agora muito favelado a playboyzada na
barra
isso aí foi a melhor coisa que aconteceu
na minha vida porque porque eu virei um
faixa preta em adaptabilidade uma versão
humana de um camaleão porque esse negro
sorridente que vos falta contando essa
história
bom quando eu tinha uns 14 anos
eu meio que só dá para ver nada com isso
puder em que poderão ver eu decidi que
eu fugi de casa se quer fugir de casa e
eu comecei a minar o rio de janeiro
inteiro visitando a agência de
intercâmbio por agência de intercâmbio
procurando oportunidade bolsa de estudos
aqui e ali e ali eu fiz o concurso
passei na prova em terceiro lugar no
brasil e fui estudar como adolescente
nos estados unidos
só que não me adaptei estados unidos
como uma família da califórnia no
primeiro dia de aula veio um professor
falou vou voltar ao futebol pelo time da
escola e eu por folgado pra caramba
carioca né
vou lavar a cara dos americanos cheguei
no estádio do futebol errada tinha um
monte de negão forte pra caraca cair na
porrada um com o outro aí eu falei opa
sakineh pra mim não fui saiu de fininho
cada um puxou pelo braço falar nessa
bola o avaí
chuta camaleão me adaptei do futebol
americano o chutador especialista em
chutes de algumas posições mais
importante
eu estudei o esporte eu puxei ferro eu
me alimentei direito ganhou 10 quilos de
músculo e menos de um ano já era um dos
maiores lutadores do estado da
califórnia
só que tem um problema eu era estudante
de intercâmbio meu visto inspirava
camaleão me adaptei
voltei para o brasil e convenci meus
pais de que eu teria que voltar para os
estados unidos eles comprar uma passagem
eu cheguei no aeroporto de miami
aí você pensa com visto de turista
brasileiro
16 anos o aeroporto de miami mês de
julho ele vai fazer excursão à disney e
foi isso que eu falei pro cara da
imigração camaleão me adaptei
voltei pro mas eu não fui pra disney não
fui para a escola queria estudar eu
queria jogar voltei me matriculei
ninguém lá sabia que estava legal me
matriculei fui para o campo para o
primeiro jogo muito bom segundo jogo
quebrou meu braço e aquela coisa nos
estados unidos
o sport anda de mãos dadas com o estudo
ea mim aquela a minha grande minha
grande esperança era que um técnico de
uma grande universidade a&m bancar me dá
uma bolsa para estudar essa grande
universidade com um braço quebrado eles
param de me ligar eu fiquei fora
temporada inteira camaleão e adaptei
pesquisar um pouco e fiquei sabendo que
tinha uma um grupo de oito universidades
nos estados unidos que davam bolsa para
estudantes estrangeiros
o problema é que eram as mais preciosas
mais caras as imagens precisam entrar e
eu não tinha nota no vestibular
só que nos estados unidos eles olham
muito além do seu nem muito além da sua
nota
e tem uma entrevista o garoto crescido
entre a barra ao complexo do alemão e à
vila da penha lapa de carioca
conquistei o cara da entrevista
quem trabalham entrei na universidade da
pensilvânia com bolsa completa
joguei futebol americano estudei três
universidades ganham conseguiu um dos
melhores empregos e podia conseguir e
com 21 anos eu estava lá em nova york
trabalhando em wall street na bolsa de
valores ou gravar duas vezes mais que o
meu pai e minha mãe juntos com 21 anos
tinha uma vida
fique ligado pô morava em times square
sair pra balada sustentável na balada só
que do dia pra noite bateu crise bateu à
bolsa de valores caiu e eu rodei
camaleão aí que acontece quando você tem
um visto de trabalho nos estados unidos
você foi demitido na sexta tinha até
quarta para sair do país
resolvi voltar pro brasil do mesmo jeito
que eu cheguei no país com uma mala em
cada mão pra me reinventar resolvi
começar a escrever é aquela coisa eu
desde pequeno eu tinha um sonho de ser
escritor
eu já tinha tentado tanta coisa que te
dá aqui tinha dado errado eu falei por
isso chegou a minha vez vou tentar isso
aí camaleão que escrevi blog escrevi um
livro que escrevi dois livros de sete
livros foi mais célere
só que chegou um momento que o mercado
em go e os acessos do meu blog também
diminuíram e agora vê o camaleão mais
brabo possível falha enorme é o seguinte
as pessoas passaram a consumir conteúdo
de uma maneira diferente
pensa assim
os escritores que a gente estuda na
escola hoje em dia são de 300 anos atrás
machado de assis shakespeare eça de
queirós daqui a 300 anos as crianças vão
estudar os setores de hoje e quem são os
credores de hoje aquela galera que liga
o seu lado fala assim é o seguinte esse
pessoal de hoje tem um poder muito maior
do que machado de assis que sei por quê
o cara você vai ler meu livro demora
três meses para ler um livro que fala
por outra pessoa ela vai demorar mais
seis meses para terminar daqui a um ano
a terceira pessoa vai ler um livro é um
processo muito lento e é por isso que
muitos escritores naquela época só
conseguiu notoriedade depois que eles
morriam
que desperdício o escritor de hoje
aperta um botão que a mensagem dele já
está na frente de milhões e milhões de
pessoas
e aquela coisa enquanto escritor do
passado e morava 300 páginas para passar
a mensagem dele
hoje o cara precisa ser rápido direto e
conciso e passar aquilo tudo e 15
segundos quando eu acho que toda moda
antiga
à moda antiga dois anos atrás eu tinha
10 mil seguidores
camaleão qual a diferença entre um e
outro
estou falando de livros lembrou um livro
que foi escrito alguns milhares de anos
atrás eu de vez em quando tem uma
passagem que diz assim honrar pai e mãe
o rayyan escrito à moda antiga ele
queria ser que ele ganha muito dinheiro
para se mostrar para os outros
hoje tentar descer champanhe na balada e
apareceu pra mulherada trabalham hoje eu
escrevo trabalho fico rico pensando meu
pai da minha mãe porque a grande
diferença
sou formado em economia e mais um pouco
de contabilidade e eu tenho certeza que
o sistema tá quebrado
daqui a alguns anos não vai ter um
excesso para ele nem no brasil nem nos
estados unidos nem na europa previdência
uma pirâmide financeira enorme um rapaz
mãe
hoje eu escrevo trabalho por causa dos
meus pais e eles
já estava tudo que eles iam para me
deixar onde estou até hoje porque é
aquela coisa com grandes poderes vêm
grandes responsabilidades
as pessoas comuns têm um pai uma mãe às
vezes um pai ou uma mãe eu tenho um pai
uma mãe e um pai adotivo que me salvou o
time e imigrante ilegal nos estados
unidos e um tiro que não tem filhos e é
mais do que um pai pra mim como eu falei
com grandes poderes vêm grandes
responsabilidades do trabalho tensão
neles todos porque eu contei essa
história de um imigrante ilegal que
virou jogador de futebol americano que
foi trabalhar na bolsa de valores que
começou a escrever livros e depois
passou a escritora a ser escrito assim
porque pra mostrar que dá para usar no
mundo onde 99% das pessoas são
consumidas pelo medo medo de arriscar
medo de ficar pobre meio de um certo
medo de ser motivo de chacota
- não tem a aprovação da família medo de
ser diferente
camaleão tem medo ele tem se não tivesse
medo ele não trocaria de compra se
proteger do predador 99% dessas pessoas
consumidas pelo medo só estão assim
porque elas ignoram e escondem aquela
que é a maior habilidade um ser humano
pode ter
adaptabilidade então quando bateu um
medo faltar coragem para ousar mudar e
botar a cara pensa no inss do seu pai e
da sua mãe
e lembre se de uma só palavra
trabalham muito obrigado
[Aplausos]